bonjour parce qu'on vous parle de choses
sérieuses mais qu'on se prend pas au
sérieux parce que le rire c'est bon pour
la santé
on vous parle du festival l'humour
bienvenue sur notre site ktm adjoint
d'affirmer si oui par quelques terrasses
où l'ennemi de minables rien eu
d'évident propose des ratés enfants les
à la forte houle et fêter ou des faits
10 p 3 oui peut-être noura trois vagues
locaux l'occasion bien occupé en bout ne
lui disent pas ce qu'elle a dans mon
pays bien maladroit bout de mon fils
mais lorsqu'un internaute y défendre
quoique bonjour messieurs
alors pour nous parler aujourd'hui d'une
nouvelle création
deux comédiens de caf punk alors c'est
qui le caf c'est qui le punk là sur les
bords du peuple mais pas favoris dans
lequel les caf avons présenté est un
petit peu de diou comment vous ai trouvé
est arrivé à cette création
en fin de compte - une ville nouvelle
occasion de travail sur un projet à
l'époque il ya 4-5 comme ça c'est ça
leur sert quatre ministères avaient
moins l'huile avec maroni et n'avait
qu'un trio comme ça fait un spectacle
comme ça que ça peut être sept
ministères que j'avais je suis pas bien
fonctionné même si elle devait produire
voilà hélas après les trente ans thierry
là avec l'occasion du festival de mouna
de nous qu'un bain de temps puisqu'on
avait joué ensemble sur les spectacles
cyrielle etienne d'un petit truc avec
clermont utilisé le mot magique qui se
passe en mode et nico jour quelqu'un
c'est un moment magique quand même
beaucoup plus que ça entre nous avec la
célèbre statue ça c'est un art fair
alors donc un petit casse passée là des
fonctionnaires nadia nous espionner sur
une maria liste mais pourquoi pas pour
le festival d'humour monter un jour en
jour comme il peut et est d'ailleurs de
mémoire micro à pas jusqu'à présent
qu'il a eu des duos comiques à la
réunion une
de deux gars à nou lé là dans le hall du
théâtre départementaux peu de montanou
un petit but et donne envie donner pour
à corte allez viens assassinat scène la
scène de 9 7 4 tv alors authentique ou
l' histoire que la fin d'un film
commence travail de son histoire le ska
tu réécris le ghana des problèmes là et
les savons les psychologues écoles voilà
ce colloque ce problème c'est qu'on a
mieux personnellement tous les biens
parce que où la chasse est la plus
commerçante est soustraite chat c'était
une expérience à ou personnellement dès
qu ils racontent des histoires aux
terrains de plein de sujets voler une
traite d'un sujet qui revient souvent
c'est les rapports de voisinage vous la
voulez avoir un sujet aussi sur la
partie sur l'homosexualité mais vu du
côté des parents des deux 2 passionnel
ou trois ans ça parce que souvent nous
nous vivons et nous à la personne
concernée mais mais les parents les
parents réellement par rapport aux
environnements comme aux activités et le
créole et le caf les collines un
problème personnel comme on lit ça
présente seul devant un professionnel de
santé
je connais une manière là on dit timide
ci a tout à fait les vrais moins timide
je me dis qu est ce qui serait possible
je suis branché votre idiotie chien
zilli pourrait arrêter pis si mon
portail surtout est-ce que tout fait
rire et fait rien tout le monde on y
pense que oui il faut savoir comment
leur accompagnement
le real higuain fait rien du tout mais
seulement là où férié les gens c o keefe
hérissé pas entrer qui colle au tas ce
visa assez les mots qu'on va di ballo
finition c'est les mots que va dit au
moment que va dire et comment on va y
aller et là aux ferries mais seulement
bien géré ça pour pas que l'autisme est
visée on veut décoincer rim mais ne pas
être coincé ou connais bien
de l'avis motivé ni ne peut pas avoir un
problème de santé que le siggraph
comment ça non le pacs n'est pas grave -
les malbars est à nous comment quand on
apprend notre histoire prend pas
l'histoire là où il est susceptible
comme ça dont les beckham découvrir ce
parcours histoire des mois je coupe un
du coup c'est le festival de l'humour
quoi si on peut faire rire les gens mais
il faut donner envie aux gens de venir
voir lofficial de l'humour
s'ils commencent à embrouilles camarades
de c'est un dieu que vous êtes
rencontrés séparément ne reprendra pas
de bocquet est bon c'est bon l'idée de
cette émission c'est de dire aux gens
poussez les portes des théâtres
départementaux venez ici venez vous voir
venez rire mais pourquoi pourquoi à
l'udc et les halles une télé tous les
joueurs regardent qu'est ce qui se passe
autour de l'eau mais si tentante avec
tout ce qui se passe avec cette prison
d'adra du moderne aujourd'hui ces temps
en temps la passe et petite fenêtre
d'ouverture ou gagneront des noms
pouvoir à six au total
est-ce qu'il faut dire aussi une valable
si colas est bien plus forte et pendant
une heure et demie où les là on prend
plein la tronche on oublie tout
relâchement est sorti le moment là sont
guéris là où ça c'est le monde est né
road house tout le monde connaît thierry
jardinot jean laurent faubourg ce qui
est amarrée à l'iss des gens qui ont
fait leur place et depuis de nombreuses
années on connaît beaucoup moins les
autres c'est vrai mais où mes honnorat
on a le même problème en métropole on a
géniale idée on avoue mais les gens dès
hier on a un paquet entre ça et bien ses
aveux tenait parquet aussi tombe dans
l'oubli mais il faut se battre tout
simplement n'est pas facile mais il faut
aller à la nar forme de dents et il faut
que le petit fait qu'on fait les petits
bce pour moi je reconnais
c'est pas votre métier c'est pas le
petit en annexe i am il y en a tant de
mal au vent de la diarrhée
un jeune âge il a au coin soucier des
paumés dans l'arctique en son nom mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas du métier mais
c'est pas notre métier mais à côté
n'est-elle rester poli et demande
tellement d'investissement concert
devient un deuxième métier et ben merci
messieurs bon courage et merci bon
festival l'humour on va vous vous avez
compris le message
le rire fait partie de la culture et la
culture ben elle est pour tous
on est d'accord vous l'assuré peut juste
pas juste un petit truc qu'elle à la
halle aux membres dédié aux gens que
c'est valu deux mois un petit peu
disparu et c'est là que le mot et
revient donc fait sous la lune voilà il
faut lui pérennise ali dans le temps
folie tron a thing est à toi prédit
grandi mais poulies grandi là il ya
besoin de l'eau et de l'eau c'est quoi
c'est le public à leur mamie timmins
tout l'étrange date où les classes
sociales paix que ce festival de noah
devient votre festival deux mois et de
20 autres moments de rire parce qu'on
voit à la fois des commandes mais là on
a besoin écrit donc là bravo à thomas
jane au festival d'humour mais garantit
à jacques prévert mort d'éric la scène
ça c'était pas un petit message tu es un
gros message en tout cas à bientôt dans
les théâtres départementaux et sur 9 7 4
tv